hey there neighbors and naysayers it's
clint finney again for another eastern
ohio grazing council
web update hey sorry that we haven't
been in touch here in the last few weeks
we have been
very busy in the office this is equipped
contracting period for
beth and i and all the rest of the nrcs
soil and water folks
we just been swamped at the office and
didn't have a time to
to put out an update or or do a past
year walk
but the good news is we're going back
pastor walking this month and so
we wanted to do one last update
before we go past your walking so let's
get started
i thought i'd talk just a second about
what we're looking for with grass
this time of year we talked about
leaving the forage or
ochre grass and fescue to third leaf
stage we did that in this field
um and so what what is it that we're
looking for now and
last three days i've come home and dad
daddy said well they didn't eat nothing
he said it's not down we we don't need
to move them yet tonight
well my answer is it always they always
need to move no matter what
um if i errored and gave them too big a
field and they didn't eat it all then
that's my fault not there so
but outside of that
our theory this time of year is we just
want them to top graze we just want them
to graze off the top
leaf and i'm standing here looking down
the fence for a reason because you can
kind of see the difference
uh if i pan one way very slowly
and you see that you say boy that's not
enough they didn't eat any of that
but then if you look down the fence you
can see the difference
between the two the important point here
is
we're just trying to keep it vegetative
we're just trying to graze the top
growth
keep it vegetative for as long as we
possibly can
we only get these six seven months of
growth
to be able to graze um newly grown grass
and we need to make the most of those
six seven months
so that we can graze the rest of the
year we hope and that's one big
difference too and i keep
in my mind is right now it's totally
different i'm just trying to keep it
vegetative
come august first i won't have
everything graced i don't
i want all the mob grazing pretty much
to be over by then
or at least i want enough mob graze
stuff ahead
of me to get to november 1st
so it's a smaller area it's not taking
out my whole farm and while i'm grazing
that i've got the whole farm
graze are growing for stockpiled grass
we've got to do a better job of taking
advantage of the days that we're given
to grow grass we can't waste them we
can't waste sunshine and rain
during the growing season in favor of
the non-growing season so
everything about what we do for grass
and grass management should be
not wasting those vegetative days
keeping that plant vegetative as long as
we possibly can
just uh saw this as i was coming in you
can see the post
sticking up there that's a fence that i
just took down it was three strand had
the sheep
on the left side cows on the right side
and you can kind of see why
because we called the right side the
badlands because it's
very steep a very rough slips
and tends to grow up in waterflower rows
and we've got some modifier rose control
ahead of us we've
done part of this field last year we'll
do the rest of it hopefully this year if
it gets dry enough but anyway
what i wanted to show was the difference
in grazing height
from one side to the other now granted
the sheep field has had
let's see one two three four five days
of rest five days more than the cow side
but it's a stark difference in the
grazing height
i hope you all can see that but
uh in five days we've got some really
massive regrowth on the sheep side
where it's only been two days since the
cows were on this side so
i haven't really got the regrowth yet
but it just shows
what we really look for in the spring if
i have my drillers i want the fields to
graze like the left side
more than the right side the reason this
is grazed like this is because
you can see it's a pathway to get to
another field so
they graze it tight because they're
going toward that gate but um
i know that the left side doesn't look
like it's grays it doesn't look like
it's grazed enough but if you get out
there in there
you may find in this one acre field you
may find 10 seed heads
baby seed heads just starting to come
out the rest have all been nipped off
and that will keep that plant vegetative
until next rotation
next rotation hopefully they'll nip them
10 off but they'll leave 10 behind and
we'll still have 10 seed heads but
hopefully we keep it a little more
vegetative this way and we're growing a
forage bank
ahead of us this way take home message
is
i know it doesn't look grazed in the
spring
when we only graze this much but the
regrowth is going to be so much more and
this is something we want to carry
kind of through the entire season if we
let them graze too close
early in the season it tends to allow
them to over graze through the rest of
the season
kevin's talked about going out and
mowing with a with a this mower
at a four inch height and it kind of
makes that bottom of that plant that
four inches
kind of makes it stemmy and harder
and more lignified i guess woody i guess
is the term for it
and that keeps the the cows from grazing
down so low
and that's kind of what we want to do
with the cows rather than doing it with
a mower if we can
or sheep or whatever we're grazing with
but
i know it's hard this is the roughest
time of year to graze
it's the time when i make the most
mistakes believe me i make them tons of
them
i got a field right now that one side is
not grazed enough the other side's
grazed too much
should have moved him last night but it
was pouring down rain and that's just
the way things
go so just a little picture of
what i like to see i like to see it just
nipped off
this stuff's going to grow so fast we're
going to get back to it we'll leave that
forage bank we'll get back to it later
that will come in handy later on the
season when things slow down
one question i get this time of year all
the time and it's something that i
struggle with as well
is uh the sorting that we see out there
when
the cows first go out how much they
graze certain patches really tight in
certain patches they don't seem to
hardly touch
and and i've struggled with that for
years and how to make that right and how
how to get them to
graze more uniformly the entire pasture
field
just happened to be watching a video
from dr alan williams
and gabe brown and they suggested that
that we just didn't have the animal
impact that we needed to we weren't
having we didn't have as many pounds per
acre as we should have
to get them to graze that more uniformly
and it's tough to do
this time of year even for someone like
me who regularly
has a very high stocking rate per acre
when i'm grazing
it's tough to get those high stalking
rates this time of year and so
uh dr alan williams proposed a a
scenario
a way to fix our sorting problems or our
non-uniformity of our grazing
is to to to create a really high
stocking density
for a short duration of of each day for
several days five to seven days
uh in length and that will will tell the
cows that they need to go ahead
and be uniform in their grace and not go
and sort and select
certain plants so i started doing that
at our place
i just built a small paddock turn the
cattle into the field
just leave them there for half an hour
or an hour and then
go back in a half an hour an hour and
move them into their bigger field what
will last them for a 12 hour period or a
day
depending on what i'm going to do and
whether i'm going to be home to move
them or not
and it seems to be working it seems to
have have made the cows be more
uniform in their selection of the field
rather than going out and patchy
sort of grazing and not getting
everything by doing this just building a
small
paddock turning them in there making a
really high stocking density for that
half hour an hour and then turn them
into the bigger
field later uh seems to be working it
seems to actually
be making those cows graze those fields
more uniformly
just thought i'd pass that along some
the rest of you may be struggling with
grazing uniformity this time of year and
and i think this is one way that we can
kind of train our cows to be more
uniform in their grazing pattern
well i'm out moving the sheep it's about
seven o'clock at night
got one lamb there got the rest of them
gonna come with lambs here
pretty soon everybody's excited
one thing i wanted to show
and the sheep are going to course in the
background is we get a question all the
time
how big should my paddocks be and and
that answer always
always gets a government answer it
depends now there's about
30 ewes in this bunch weighing about a
hundred pound
there's 16 fat lambs
in here again weighing about 100 pounds
and they're getting ready to start
lambing so
you can figure that based on body weight
how many pounds and how many inches and
all that that we need but
what i'll show you is one way that i do
it without doing math and
those of you that know me say but you
love doing math and i do
but we can make this work for those who
are not math inclined
so what i have try not to make you sick
here by
but i want to show you best angle what i
have is
the field they were in yesterday
this field was they were in sunday till
sunday night
so they were in saturday morning at 10
o'clock they came in this field
and they went out on sunday at six
o'clock the reason they came over here
was because they started landing and
they were clean at the back of the farm
and i don't want them back at the farm
because there's no houses no nothing
close by the nearest thing to them there
is dylanville and it's about
3 000 feet straight down over the hill
so um
coyote heaven so we wanted to bring them
up closer to the barns and i can pay and
show you the
barns are right there and we'd be
working toward the barns as they start
lambing but
unfortunately we had this first set of
lambs and
and we haven't had any more and that
happens sometimes we start and it goes
great guns and we have tons of lambs and
sometimes we start we get a couple days
and then we get another one in a couple
days and all of a sudden bang we get
tons of lambs but
so what we did you can see my fence
daughter with my flower rose there
that's a permanent three-strand fence
runs down the middle of this field
makes these paddocks 263 feet wide
the posts are on 32 foot center so
that's how i calculate
what i'm gonna do with my fences so i
gave them
five posts not knowing how much forage
was in this field and how much
we needed to give them i i
split it into five posts per paddock
put them in this field and as luck would
have it it was raining
sunday i didn't want a movement 10
o'clock because that gets them off
schedule for me to
move them again the next day
so i just
left them there i left them there to
figure out
whether that was enough or whether it
was too much or what came up here
between the raindrops six o'clock sunday
and this field is grazed what i consider
to be
perfectly first new spring growth and
i'll try to bend down and show you
new spring growth just right just tipped
the ends of the fescue plants
ate the clover but not too low
um just a perfect grace so
the way we figure our paddocks here is
and you're gonna say well
you left them here for more than 24
hours how's that perfect well the way we
do that is
they were in here for 32 hours
five posts 32 hours divide that out
multiply it by 24
and you get 3.75 posts i know most of
you didn't want to do the math what i'm
saying is
five posts was too much for 24 hours so
reduce it down by one post
see how it goes the next day if it's too
much
reduce it down again if it's too little
give them a little bit more
if your whole field is is of one height
you can do that i mean it doesn't hurt
to to figure it out with the animals how
much
actually needs to be out there it's
actually a good way to figure out
backward how many pounds of animal we
have out here in the field
figure out how much grass you have how
many pounds per inch figure out how much
they ate in 24 hours
that'll give you a pretty good idea how
many pounds you've got out there without
a scale
it's not going to be perfect it's not
may not even be close but at least it's
a number for you to do but
that's how i do my paddock divisions
especially with the cows later in the
summer i start into a field
give them a piece next day is that too
much is it too little
well i'll give them a little more give
them a little less until we get about
right and then once the spring flush
really hits
we're very rarely ever wrong we're gonna
be
right more than not i mean and then your
grazer's eye kicks in too and you look
at this field and say well this one's a
little thinner or this one's a little
thicker let's give them a little more
let's give them a little less
but we're not going to err that bad by
doing it i mean we're going to leave
some forage behind and that's what we
want to do anyway but
um just a good way to come up with what
size should your paddocks be in and yet
another reason
for those of you that don't like
temporary fence this is the reason why
we use temporary fence as i said this
this these two paddocks are 263 feet
wide they're 1200 feet long
so i can make my paddocks bigger or
smaller depending on what we need
once i put the steers in with these
lambs and sheep once they're done
lambing
we'll go back up so we'll go back up
usually it's around five posts that's
why i started with five and then worked
my way down but
um just a good way to figure out what
size your panics need to be and because
i've got temporary fence i can make them
smaller or bigger
and because i've got temporary fence i
can take this all down
spread fertilizer spread manure winter
feed on it whatever it is i want to do
i can mow it all at one time brush all
get all at one time
i can mow portions of it at one time if
i want to so
just a good quick lesson on how we
size our paddocks i hope that wasn't too
complicated but
it's really not if you break it down to
its bare bits we we just give them a
piece of grass and we come back and
check on them every couple hours over
the weekend
we know when it gets exactly right and
then we
divide it out depending on the hours
when you like to do the math that's fine
if not
give them 24 hours if it's too much
make it smaller if they ate too little
the other way around and just go from
there
hey little guy i'm not your mama your
mama's over there
there's your mama
people often wonder how we move sheep
with little lambs like that well we try
not to move them when they're brand new
but that little guy's six days old today
so
he's moving pretty good now we don't
have any trouble moving them once
they're that way
uh when we start having bunches and
lambs we just don't back fence it
every day uh it makes kind of a pain
cause i gotta take fence down and put it
back up but
i do i take it down let them
find their way back to the new grass
every day i try to get a big field so
that i don't have to move them from
field to field when we lay them
well that's a wrap for this week's
eastern ohio grazing council update
if you haven't been added to our mailing
list please drop beth or iron email
that'll get you email notifications of
when we post videos but also
our pastor walk flyers and any other
eastern ohio grazing council information
at this point i can't say how excited i
am as well as all the rest of the folks
involved with eastern ohio grazing
council are
to say we are going back faster walking
we are going back to live and in-person
pasture walks
may 27th at 6 p.m we're gonna be going
up and visit
mr hours grazing operation outside
lisbon ohio hosted by the columbianas
county soil and water conservation
district we do hope to see all of you
there it is going to be exciting to go
back to live and in person
pasture walks discussions and to see all
of you
uh that we haven't seen in over a year
now we will be following all the covet
19 protocols social distancing and the
like
we have asked you all to bring your own
lawn chairs to the event
things will be a little different but we
will be back to live
and in person pastor walks again i can't
say how excited i
am that that's gonna happen i can't say
how excited
we are to to get together again uh and
also
to be doing it in person instead of in
video format
it's going to be great to to get to go
back to pasture walks and
and have discussion led by the folks who
are hosting the
the county and hosting the pastor walk
and see what they're doing in their
county and also on their grazing
operation
i guess that leads me to what are we
gonna do
with these web updates uh we've had
considerable discussion and had
considerable input over the last several
months of
uh how much folks enjoyed having these
web updates and
quite honestly when we started doing
this we were just filling the void we
wanted to make sure that the eastern
ohio grazing council folks
still got timely grazing information
that they were
used to from the in-person pasture walks
but would do it in video form
and we've had several folks uh
call in to say you know we like what
you're doing and we hope you keep doing
it
and it's beth and i's hoping and our
plan to go ahead and video
our live and in person pasture walks in
the future get them edited and get them
posted to our youtube channel
beth and i have also had considerable
discussions about
whether we were going to continue to do
some updates now and then and and i
think both of us believe it's
still a good thing to do some in-person
updates
uh with things that we see in the field
some topics of discussion
some timely grazing information that may
not have been talked about at the
previous pasture walk
and and may not get talked about or may
be too late to talk about at our next
past
walk so uh it's our plan to still go
ahead and do some
some eastern ohio grazing council
updates from time to time uh
i guess my vision is to do some updates
uh in the two-week interval between
pastor walks we got four weeks between
pasture walks to post them about two
weeks after the previous and two weeks
before the
next pastor walk as time and information
allows
so with that i'll also say if any of you
have any
timely updates topics ideas suggestions
or if you've got some video that you'd
like for us to take a look at and
maybe post as an eastern algorithm
council update we would be glad to do
that
we'd also be glad to have those topics
discussions ideas
for pastor walks in the future i i think
that's the vision for what we want to do
as far as the the eastern ohio grazing
council web updates go
i think we're going to be glad to go
ahead and post those
pastor walk videos just for those folks
who can't attend our live and in person
pasture walks and
we'll see what the future holds as far
as web updates and
things i can't say again how excited i
am
to go back to pasture walks i'm sure the
rest of the eastern ohio grazing council
would echo that sentiment we're going to
be glad to see all of you and have live
and in-person discussion and see where
that discussion takes us
on the topics of grazing livestock in
eastern ohio and what we're seeing
on our own farms so with that
i hope to see you may 27th at 6 pm at mr
hours grazing operation
uh there's going to be the flyer coming
up here after this slide just giving you
the
other information about the pasture walk
and i'll say
we'll see you next time
you